[Musique]
mais tu pourrais trouver ce même genre
d'histoire ce même genre de personnage
dans des bouquins pourquoi l'ordinateur
c'est plus vivant
risqué dans le monde des jeux vidéo ça
n'est pas forcément une partie de
rigolade
pour alexandre c'est même souvent une
question de vie ou de mort quand on
commence à perdre le niveau de vie
commence à baisser alors ça l'angoissé
monte un peu plus alors il faut toujours
à chaque fois tu es un autre ennemi pour
essayer d'avoir un point de vie et je
pense que c'est je baille il ya toujours
ce même truc qui se répètent ce canton
va en arrive à un point de vie ou à
essayer on va mourir et un jeu continue
il fallait plus vite
allez c'est assez angoissant mais il
aime beaucoup jouer ce jeu vidéo mais je
lui dis avec modération comme tout parce
que sinon ça prend des proportions après
qui dépasse un petit peu l'entendement
de l'étude même de la vie familiale
parce qu'ils y restent enfermés pendant
des heures entières et à mon avis pas
vraiment le but recherché en fait une
distraction
ça doit pas devenir une chose
complètement j'avais pas lu hier en
catalogne qui leur fait peur fait ça qui
va nous manger dans un siècle où je
passe et la violence dans les jeux ça ça
te motive
non je trouve ça complètement débile
parce que il ya déjà je ne vois pas à
quoi ça sert de tuer deux femmes quand
on est un homme je parle rambo par
exemple un jeu là on doit tuer on doit
tuer tout sur son passage on va des
lieux de délibéré les libérer les otages
moi quand je vois ça me désespère
la violence pimentent en effet une bonne
dose de jeux vidéo on cogne on flingue
on a tout misé une seule règle ne pas
faire de détail beaucoup en raffolent du
moment que cela reste un jeu
je robocop et bon jeu tu l'a donc par
exemple si j'étais vraiment robocop si
j'étais dans la réalité vraiment je
pourrais pas moi dans la vie je peux pas
tout
c'est une sorte d'aidé d'exutoire pour
un pour les jeunes eux et 90 die dans la
rue de mal tourner on préfère je vais
dire frappé un personnage dans un
moniteur que dans la rue et s'énerver
pour que ça ça canalise plus tôt tu dire
non nos instincts bestiaux
si je peux dire le phénomène du jeu
vidéo après une telle ampleur qu un
salon lui est désormais consacré 80 %
des joueurs sont des garçons âge moyen
14 ans certains mordus passe jusqu'à
huit heures par jour devant leur écran
selon toi vous au dessus de jean
réductions dans ce labyrinthe
surréaliste il est souvent difficile de
trouver la porte de sortie
dominique travaille chez laurie ciel une
société française de jeux vidéo
son job dépanner les joueurs pris au
piège il leur fournit les clés pour
arriver jusqu'au bout de l'histoire
s'il ya des gens aussi agressif
vous prennent à partie parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à finir un jeu oui tout à
fait oui c'est assez souvent on se
traite de tous les noms on est la plus
mauvaise sociétés du monde où plein de
sortes de choses je sais qu'il ya des
solutions que je n'ai plus dans le
dossier si on peut pas les renvoyer
c'est la fin du monde c'est fini
chaque jour 7000 appels au secours 25000
en période de vacances
on ne chante pas aux standards de chez
nintendo leader de l'industrie du jeu
vidéo lumière artificielle air
conditionné 40 standardiste vivent dans
une sorte de bunker installé dans la
banlieue parisienne
on les appelle les mutants du matin au
soir
ils répondent aux questions en testant
simultanément deux nouveaux jeux sur
votre chemin lorsque vous avez fini vous
avez vaincu le bateau le fils de coupe à
l'enfant de coupât lorsque vous avez
complètement tué d'un monde à l'autre
les jeux vidéo peuvent vous mener très
loin parfois jusqu'à l'intoxication
pendant un temps ça a été ma drogue
parce que je sache romney j'étais sur ma
console et je pose mon sac j'étais
toujours sur ma console
il ya des soirs où je mangeais pas j'ai
été jetée devant ma console vous allez
en manger sainement [ __ ] à fin mai juste
est toujours en train de jouer pendant
un temps je jouais tellement que j'avais
les mains qui tremblaient et ça reprend
exactement les mouvements que je faisais
sur un joystick chaque week-end burwell
et ses copains se défoulent sur un divan
ils vivent ta vannes dans le morbihan et
vous aimeriez jouer avec des adultes
ça serait intéressant ça serait bien
voilà c'est son meilleur que nous je
trouvais que le roi elle passait
vraiment beaucoup de temps devant la
télévision
j'avais pas vraiment beaucoup de temps
pour moi en occuper j'ai donc trouvé ce
moyen de façon à démythifier la
télévision et puis de le faire devenir
un petit peu plus active devant sa
télévision
il reste toujours autant de temps devant
un écran
en fait son attitude était différente
il était devant un écran mais il n'était
plus affalé dans un fauteuil il était il
était actif il réfléchissait enfin ils
étaient obligés de chercher quelque
chose et c'est ça qui m'a intéressé dans
les premiers jeux qui lui n'est que je
vais acheter
[Musique]
pour nombre de parents le jeu vidéo
devient la nouvelle baby sitter
sécurisante v culpabilisant une
compagnie pour l'enfant parfois un
refuge lorsque la cellule familiale
éclats beaucoup d'enfants avoue ne plus
avoir joué à autre chose qu'aux jeux
vidéo
[Musique]